California Governor Jerry Brown just
took another swipe at the president's
crackdown on criminal immigrants Brown a
Democrat over the weekend pardoned a
pair of immigrants convicted felonies to
try to save them from deportation one of
them guilty of a gang-related weapons
charge
can president Trump stopped the Golden
State from becoming a sanctuary state
for such felons joining us now for
debate from San Diego is John Cox the
Republican candidate for governor and in
Fort Worth Texas Francisco Hernandez an
immigration Eternity attorney so
Francisco I want to start with you to
lay the legal ground here I think people
have a lot of questions about how a
pardon from a state governor for state
crimes shields and immigrant with a
felony from deportation which is a
federal responsibility well because he
he pardoned the underlying offenses
which is about as effective as President
Trump
pardoning Yosemite Sam over in Arizona
you can't pardon somebody who didn't at
least admit they've done something wrong
but bottom line it doesn't matter we've
got to resolve this issue if we're
talking the difference of deporting
someone who's admitted to a criminal
offense nobody to the felony here I mean
people really have questions about why
is it that a state governor is is can
pardon these crimes that is that
something governor's do all the time but
how does that shield someone from a
deportation well it may or may not it
doesn't matter
we're Sona Georgia okay in these state
laws john cox you're running for
governor in california does it not
matter
yeah named cox yeah it matters really it
matters Katie as you said because the
first job of any governor is to protect
the people and what Jerry Brown
continues to do mismanage this state and
expose the people of California to more
danger you know the rule of law is
sacrosanct Katie it's the thing that
protects us it's the thing that makes us
so that we don't live in chaos and we
don't live in terror of criminals
roaming the streets now I'm not saying
that's you're these people roaming their
streets but my platform is to protect
the people of this state absolutely and
you
don't do that by running gambits around
federal law by pardoning people without
a reasonable justification and you're
doing for you question for your friend
francisco california be making decisions
for the people of his state when it
comes to allowing felonies back out
felons back on the streets to get back
at Donald drop really the way he must be
running the state you've given him the
victory he cannot part in a federal deal
he doesn't matter what he does in state
law he can pardon and it doesn't
this guy still the federal government
still support this guy's just because
they pled guilty and this guy Cox is
running for governor against and that's
the best thing you can be a princess
fine I'm not you can he can the federal
government through immigrations and
Customs Enforcement still support this
guy based on his felony weapons charge
okay John excuse me may I may I respond
excuse me
yes thank you Katie yeah I'm a
businessman Katie I've got to solve
problems I've also got to make sure the
rules are enforced what Governor Brown
is doing with this kind of action is
sending a message to people frankly
people who are already in prison and who
were wondering why they aren't gain
pardoned as well you know he's saying a
message that the rule of law doesn't
matter and you know the thing that
separates us from a lot of countries
around the world Katie that are in chaos
that are not successful is that in this
country we enforce the rule of law this
is why they're making California a
sanctuary state is so unproductive you
know I'm a businessman you have to solve
problems we have to actually address the
problem of illegal immigration and
protection of our citizens and we're not
going to do that as long as we have
politicians crass politicians like Jerry
Brown and frankly GameSalad we'll get up
you're pleased I'll run back to you how
is it that states like California and
cities sanctuary cities are still
getting away with where there is no such
thing as sanctuary sanctuary state
picking up anybody the federal
government can take these folks right
back right now we are so you know what
hey you sure you know you right you
should transfer so you should tell that
to the family of a young woman who was
murdered in Northern California because
the authorities there did not inform the
federal authorities when they released a
guide from printer question we all know
about that case we're gonna move on to
this time for governor Francisco this is
- is this a good resource of resources
from the federal the state government to
be using pardons to pardon immigrants
who have felony records the pardon does
not matter let's get on to the detail
why it doesn't matter why does not
matter no I'm here for the 11 million
people commit a zero offenses pay taxes
we're not talking about that who are
gonna be the better maybe not I mean
they're being protected by a state that
won't turn them over to ice we're
letting the tail wag the dog
okay over to you John no need to respond
I'm dangerous we're working we're
dancers leave it all out we're late
we're laying dangerous people out on the
- to hurt people in the community we've
got to make sure that the rule of law is
enforced we've got to send a message to
everybody that the rule of law is going
to be enforced and if I'm elected
governor of California it will and and
and that's that's that's what the first
rule and that's the first role of a
governor is just to protect the people
know and Jerry Brown is letting the
people Public Safety quit class where do
you Francisco and know is my goodness
know you've run for governor yes damn
for the rule law you don't take on
immigration issues federal issues that
you've got nothing to do with Jerry
Robin is inserting himself by using the
pardon power that's the problem here as
a rule of law and he's inserting himself
in the situation we know that the
governor pardoned these two immigrants
they had criminal records they did their
time and now we know they're friends
Francisco says they can still be
deported under federal law so we'll see
where it goes from there thank you folks
for coming on the show b4 Shanna cute
baby thank you thank you